uno de los primeros en lanzar la
rebelión contra boris johnson el
ministro de finanzas risas unax se
apresuró a anunciar su candidatura a la
cabeza del partido conservador y por
tanto a primer ministro
me presento para ser el próximo líder
del partido conservador y su primer
ministro
a sus 42 años risas una que es parte de
una joven generación de conservadores
tras estudiar en la universidad de
oxford comenzó su carrera como analista
en goldman sachs fue elegido diputado
por primera vez en 2015 y apoyó el break
sheet en los debates previos al
referendo de 2016 se incorpora al
gobierno de theresa may en 2018 como
secretario de estado para el gobierno
local yonhap ascendió rápidamente en el
escalafón oryzon sólo nombró el
secretario jefe del tesoro en 2019 y
luego ministro de finanzas en 2020
cuando la crisis del cob y 19 golpeó al
país anunció un importante plan de
recuperación
hoy anunció un estímulo fiscal de 30 mil
millones de libras para apoyar a los
británicos los empleos y las empresas
británicas en este momento
conocido por su conservadurismo fiscal
es una que ha hecho de la recuperación
el centro de su campaña me encantaría
estar aquí y decir mira voy a recortar
este impuesto a que el impuesto y otro
impuesto y todo estará bien pero saben
que no lo estará esta economía de algo
por nada no es conservadora es
socialismo según una encuesta realizada
entre cuatrocientos noventa y tres
miembros del partido conservador crisis
una que es del candidato más popular
entre sus compañeros por delante de la
ministra de asuntos exteriores lis atrás
hijo de un migrante indio si es elegido
sería el primer ministro no blanco del
país